(light music)
- [Narrator] Over the past few weeks,
Great Big Story and Modelo have
celebrated a town that for us
represents the best vision
for the future of America.
(chimes)
A town that's brought
together by a common spirit
of hard work and a shared
sense of community.
That spirit recently came under attack.
- [Reporter] Three men
in Kansas are facing
domestic terrorism charges.
Federal authorities say the
men were plotting to bomb an
apartment complex and mosque
filled with Somali immigrants.
We have our national correspondence...
- [Narrator] We spent a
month living in Garden City
while working on this series.
The community welcomed us with open arms,
and shared their
inspiring stories with us.
- I don't think people realize how much
energy and effort it takes to hate.
It's so much easier,
and so much less drama,
just to be loving and accepting.
I believe providing a
safe haven for people
is part of being a decent human being,
it's how we should treat each other,
and I'm glad to see we do that here.
(light music)
- Garden City make me
like my home, you know,
I feel like my home.
I would just want to live here
peaceful, making big change.
All people from Africa and
people of others live here.
I'm open the doors right now.
And I take that responsibility,
'cause I see people need help.
I will have to be united for everybody.
I'm not going nowhere.
- There's the reason all of us are here,
just to work hard and help our family.
Not to bring all these
bad things, you know,
it's not like that.
Our hearts are bigger than this.
- The world can learn a lot
about this little community,
because if we surviving
here, so many years,
and we still together, it’s because
we understand each other.
It's not only us, it's everybody.
- [Narrator] Great Big
Story and Modelo believe
in the fighting spirit.
We stand alongside
those who work together.
And we celebrate our
friends in Garden City.
(light music)
- Regardless of what color,
race, country, ethnicity,
that you are or where you've come from,
we're all here together.
Garden City's doing it.
Why can't the rest of us?
(light music)